in this video we will study about the
process of the DNA replication in part 1
of this video we discuss in detail about
the overview of DNA replication the
concept of directionality of DNA in DNA
replication and also about the various
replication enzymes that are involved in
the process now in part 2 of this video
we will study in detail about the
process of DNA replication now for the
process of DNA replication to begin it
is important for the two strands of the
DNA to open up this job is done by the
enzyme helicase which is also known as
the unzipping enzyme the enzyme helicase
performs this function by acting on the
hydrogen bonds which are present between
the base pairs of the opposite DNA
strands the helicase breaks these
hydrogen bonds due to which the double
helix opens up leading to the creation
of this structure known as the
replication fork this exposes a sequence
of DNA base pairs upon which many
enzymes will subsequently act now the
process of unzipping of DNA involves
action of multiple helices enzymes on
different segments of DNA these segments
of DNA where the enzyme helicase acts
are also known as the sites of origin
now since the helices acts on the DNA at
multiple sites multiple replication
folks are created upon which the process
of DNA replication will proceed now to
prevent the two separated strands of DNA
from joining together a special type of
protein known as the single stranded
binding protein holds the two strands of
the DNA apart according to the concept
of directionality we learn in part one
of this video let's suppose this is the
3 prime end of the upper strand and this
is the 5 prime end of the upper strand
and similarly we have the 3 prime end of
the lower strand in this direction and 5
prime end in this direction now the main
enzyme the DNA polymerase which has the
job of formation of new strands of DNA
can only form a strand from the 5 prime
to 3 prime direction
now since the upper daughter strand of
this DNA is running from
three prime to five prime direction the
DNA polymerase can easily form the
replicated opposite strand from the five
prime to three prime direction and since
the helices is also unzipping the DNA in
the same direction the DNA polymerase
can form the new strand continuously but
when we look at the opposite strand of
DNA which is running in the opposite
direction things are very different
since the DNA polymerase has to act it
has to form the new strand in this
direction which is in the 5 prime to 3
prime direction but since the helicase
is opening the DNA helix in the opposite
direction the DNA polymerase cannot
synthesize the new strand continuously
well this problem is solved by formation
of the new strand of DNA in short
segments known as the Okazaki fragments
these fragments are littering by a
different enzyme to produce one
continuous strand due to this reason the
opposite strand is known as the lagging
strand and the replication on the
lagging strand is discontinuous
replication as compared to the
continuous replication on the leading
strand now we will take the leading and
the lagging strand separately and
understand the process of DNA
replication further so after the
formation of the replication fork the
next important step is the process of
formation of RNA primer now what happens
is that the DNA polymerase enzyme can
only add new nucleotides to the three
prime end of the existing nucleotide
strand which basically means that the
DNA polymerase cannot start synthesizing
new DNA out of nowhere and basically
requires a short segment of nucleotides
so that it can add new nucleotides as a
three prime end of this sequence to form
the new DNA this problem is solved by
the enzyme RNA primase the primase makes
an RNA primer which is a short stretch
of nucleic acids complementary to the
template that provides the 3 prime end
for the DNA polymerase to work on so now
we have a leading strand of DNA which is
running from the 3 prime to the 5 prime
direction and we already have the short
primer synthesized by the enzyme prime
ace now it is a turn of the enzyme DNA
polymerase to do its job and a few
important points that you should know
about DNA polymerase are that it always
requires a primer
to work with which is a short sequence
of nucleotides and it cannot start
synthesizing the new DNA from scratch
the DNA polymerase can only add new
nucleotides at the three prime end of
the DNA and can only synthesize a new
DNA in one direction and also the DNA
polymerase requires energy for
polymerization reactions that it gets
from the nucleotides itself now once the
primer is synthesized the DNA polymerase
can perform the vital function of
elongation of DNA strand by addition of
new nucleotides through the three prime
end of the growing chain the DNA
polymerase uses the deoxyribonucleotides
which contain either of the four bases
the adenine cytosine guanine or thymine
the DNA polymerase adds these
nucleotides to one by one to the three
prime end of the new DNA strand
now since the enzyme helicase is opening
the DNA helix in the same direction the
DNA polymerase can synthesize a long
chain of new DNA before separating and
this is known as the continuous
synthesis on the leading strand the DNA
polymerase also requires energy for this
polymerization reaction which it
basically gets from breaking the
phosphate bonds present between the
triphosphates of the
deoxyribonucleotides these phosphate
bonds are high energy bonds which when
broken provide the energy for this
polymerization reaction now we will take
a look at a lagging strand which runs
from the 5 prime to the 3 prime
direction we can see that the main
problem on this strand is that the DNA
helix
is being opened up in the opposite
direction of the direction in which the
DNA polymerase synthesizes the new DNA
which is from the 5 prime to 3 prime
direction but this problem is solved by
formation of new DNA in short segments
known as the Okazaki fragments what
happens is that on the lagging strand
the primary synthesizes a short piece of
primer and then the DNA polymerase
synthesizes a short segment of DNA and
then separates from the growing end
after this the enzyme helicase would
have opened up more of the DNA helix in
this direction then again the enzyme
primary synthesizes a new primer further
up on the DNA which is followed by
formation of another short segment of
DNA this process is repeated multiple
times thus known as the discontinuous
DNA synthesis now after the DNA
polymerase has done its job the newly
DNA looks something like this it has
short segments of DNA with interrupting
segments consisting of RNA primer after
this another enzyme known as the EXO
nucleus comes into play which removes
these short segments of primers which
are then replaced by short new segments
of DNA by another type of key na
polymerase after this the enzyme DNA
ligase seals or joins the DNA fragments
to produce a continuous DNA strand even
on the lagging strand lastly it is also
important to check for errors in the
newly synthesized DNA and this is done
by another type of DNA polymerase which
proofreads the newly synthesized DNA for
any wrong bases that may have been
inserted and if it founds a wrong base
or sequence it removes the base and then
replaces it with a correct one after the
process of DNA replication is completed
the two newly synthesized DNA molecules
coil up again into the DNA helix model
so this was a brief overview about the
process of DNA replication guys thank
you so much for watching this video if
you want to see more videos like this
subscribe to our YouTube channel and for
all the flash cards and upcoming
notifications follow us on Facebook in
the link in the description below if you
want to connect to me personally you can
follow me on instagram at lost in the
north's if you are interested in travel
and landscape photography as well